welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens filling in for Eric Voss
ways out on fraternity leave and today
I'm breaking down what if season 2
episode 6 what if Kori reshaped the
world this episode is written by Ryan
little and in collaboration with the
Mohawk Nation like historian Doug George
and Mohawk language expert Cecilia King
to ensure a cultural authenticity which
is so important because this episode
means a lot to me and I'm sure a lot of
people so let's break this down scene by
scene while I point out all the small
details we might have missed but first
we have some Whata if inspired merch
over at the nerd riot. shop we have Echo
gear Loki gear uh Christmas for January
gear and I know Christmas already passed
so maybe this is just like post
Christmas January gear you know what
everybody wants go check out our awesome
merch over there it's a great way to
support the channel but also look fresh
as hell while doing it okay let's jump
into this we opened up flame scorching
everything in sight to see it's Odin
fighting serer the fire demon who
brought on Ragnarok and well you know
Thor Ragnarok and Ragnarok Thor said I
thought my father killed you like a half
a million years ago Odin had defeated
serter and then stole the Eternal Flame
the source of his power that intro shows
what would have happened if Odin had
lost the battle and the Tess fell to
Earth somewhere else we see a stunning
view of Asgard unfortunately it's
perishing but with the Tess making its
way out the Tess Falls to Earth and
landed in the honi Confederacy before
the colonization of America and that's
also the synopsis for what this
episode's about we're brought back from
the credits to a shot of corn and the
sun beaming down upon it playing is a
song by Joanne shannond a person from
the wolf Clan of the iray Confederacy
based in New York a lot of her songs
play throughout this episode she's a
brilliant singer Beautiful Mind
beautiful spirit she passed away not
long ago and her music is so gorgeous
the women began harvesting the corn then
the peas and the Squash traditional
Mohawk foods that were planted and
harvested back in the day this is their
Village and during this time they lived
in a long House made from wood frame
covered in elmark then we meet cohorte
her name is a real wolf clan name
meaning she stirs the forest or is
someone who motivates those around her
she's voiced by Dey Jacobs who plays
Bonnie and Ekko this is the introduction
of this character that hasn't been shown
in the MCU or in the comics before and
the first time a what if Episode
centered around a character who is
completely new to the MCU G is a member
of the Mohawk people who were located
around New York and even in the distant
distant distant past the MCU can't get
away from the bad happened in New
York Cory also speaks the Mohawk
language which is great because it
brings another level of authenticity to
this episode her brother's name is wat
voiced by kiano they reached the forest
they call the old Battlefield where
their ancestors bones are pinned to
trees or lying on the ground the elders
say this area is cursed but corta argues
it's only cursed because no one cleansed
it after the Bloodshed she tells a story
of how the lake that homes of tesak has
great power that would take people to
the sky world the place above land is
talked about in different creation
stories how people living there never
felt pain and had everlasting life some
said their job is to carry the messages
of the Creator and protect them from the
dangers of the universe however the
people at the time fought for control of
the lake instead of bringing them
together and this all reminds me of how
vibranium meteorite just like fell to
wakanda and how they started battling at
first there is a legend an old Mohawk
tale about the lake on the mountain and
how the daughter of a chief jumped in to
escape her arranged marriage to be with
her one true love and she never returned
out of the water the skyw woman lived
right above this Lake and it was
believed that the spirit of of the
sisters live forever in this Lake and
that Lake was called the lake of gods
Spanish explorers then attacked their
Village and I wonder what year it is cuz
during 1521 the eternals were in a
Native American city as it fell to
Spanish Invaders this must be around
that time or maybe a little bit earlier
or later also neore was born in 1571 so
he might have been around somewhere
around this time just like chilling the
Spanish are also looking for the lake
later referring to it as the Fountain of
Youth a mythical spring that helps you
never age they chase korti and wat past
the skulls back to the Forbidden Lake we
see the Forbidden Lake glow blue sheen
gorgeous and captivating interestingly
many Native American legends speak of
their people coming from below ground or
a different world and emerging into this
one the lake was underground so it would
sort of line up with the other myths
that they come from underground as well
Corte is shot in the shoulder and falls
into the Forbidden Lake upon Landing
she's immediately sucked into the cube
that guides her through a portal wrapped
in water hitting the ground we're
introduced to atrox voiced by Jeremy
white also a new character otro had
fallen through the lake years before
cohor through the Watcher we learned
that the cube broke on impact and its
energy gave power to the lake noble
people disappeared in the lake later
being deemed cursed as people fought for
it and disappeared through it telling
all to never return to it on sky world
you can see the solar system and the
village is powered by the tessex powers
even the water and the plants eating of
the land will give you Powers just
living there for a while will change you
as well back on Earth we have the
Conquistador Rodrigo Alfonso Gonzalo who
also seems to be a new character there
is a character called the Conquistador
who was the first Spaniard to find the
Fountain of Youth in the comics so he
might be based on that a little bit but
it was a very minor character there is
also another found of Youth in Marvel
Comics separate from the one found by
the Conquistador which was in Florida
this version gave a Roman Emperor named
tyrannus eternal life neither are
portals to other worlds though thank you
to better help for sponsoring this video
you can love holiday season and also
admit that it's stressful travel time
with family marking time with new
years's it can be a lot and if you feel
like you could use a little help with it
all try connecting with a licensed
therapist by using better help starting
therapy can be hard the right therapist
for you may not be in your area and some
people struggle with the face-to-face
interaction of therapy with better help
you can have your therapy sessions as a
phone call as a video chat even via
messaging if you prefer that whatever is
the most comfortable version of therapy
for you just click the link in the
description and answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for no additional cost
without stressing about insurance who's
in your network or anything like that if
you think that you might benefit from
therapy consider betterhelp click the
link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com
Stars clicking that link helps support
this Channel and also gets you 10% off
your first month of better heal so that
you can connect with a therapist and see
if it helps you during the 16th century
there were many upon many leaders of the
Spanish conquest of America this was
around the time of the queen of Spain
Isabella's Reign who were going to see
later at the end of the episode and
she's the one that funded Christopher
Columbus's Expedition so you
know her atrax mentions how the land
wants to help her another calls her a
name and she stirs the forest he also
says
this tuni there are a lot of Native
American stories of people coming from
clay one legend of the Mohawk Nation
tells a story of the good spirit using
pieces of clay they found on a river to
make man goori responds she's made of
wolf I mentioned earlier her name was a
real wolf clan name among the hoden
asoni are groups of people who come
together as families called Clans the
wolf Clan represents the Pathfinders
their responsibility is to guide the
people and living their lives in the way
of the Creator intended later he
comments got some turtle and me myself
the IRA creation Story the Earth was
created on the back of a turtle it was
there that life began to grow the Turtle
Clan represents the shifting of the
earth and the cycles of the moon so I
think those are both references to those
different Clans a bird signals its time
for the hunt and then we see these
creatures that bore fruit on their backs
that are imbued with the powers from the
world they're in they make sport of
grabbing their crystal-like fruit before
chasing after him this woman has a
flower to the sky and blows the pollen
over the cliff the creatures rise up and
begin running goori is the fastest on
the planet then we see the scene from
the trailer of her flipping the
creatures over her head a quick learner
indeed and as the sun sets goori reveals
her bundle catch the woman we saw
earlier says our names carry this
spirits and strength of those who have
been before us those under the Mohawk
Nation do have naming Traditions names
are unique to these Clans once a child
is given a name no one else can have
that name when they die the name reverts
back to the clan and is given to a new
child The Conquistadors make their way
to the sky world prepared to colonize it
when kahori stops the bullets from
penetrating the sky people she goes off
on them telling them how they need to
step up and remember where they began
and how important it is to help she says
You' forgotten your Origins but I cannot
she pulls the portal to her and then she
leaves arriving on the edge of the
waters where the people are being taken
she arrives and literally begins laying
these men out they refer to her as a
witch because she's so powerful she uses
her Newfound powers to stop the cannon
balls from penetrating and overall that
the prophecy song plays by Joanne sheno
one makes its way through though hitting
her in the head and the rest of the
people from sky world appear and they
helped they followed her cohor really
living up to her name and motivating
others they crossed the waters running
through the ships and Ki freeze her
people telling her brother to witness
their deeds remember their faces we're
going to need new songs about today the
brother says Thunder beans and there are
Mohawk Legends of Thunder spirits who
live in the sky and can bring death to
Mortals although they typically pay a
positive role in Mohawk Legends The
Watcher says very seldom Heroes stop
after their first Victory and you're not
going to stop corty here then we're
taking to Spain the man talking to the
queen says
this this could be a reference to
Gonzalo JZ de consada who set out to
find El Dorado with 500 men and came
back with only 25 the Mendoza Brothers
could also come from Pedro de mza who
came from a noble family in Spain he
messed up in bueno's areas and dipped
leaving his forces behind and died on
his way back to Spain then arrives
kohori who tells her to freaking quit it
and even with the queen being a dick she
offers a peace offering then Steven
strange enters the chat AKA strange
Supreme we last Saw strange Supreme
Being put in charge of the pocket
Dimension containing kilmonger and
Ultron it's unclear what he wants with
korti as she is imbued with the space
Stone she might have the powers to
travel other realities there may be some
other large threat that the Supreme
needs to put a team together to stop
similar to what happened last season we
know the final episode is what if
strange Supreme intervened I think he
could be using coori to help clean up
whatever mess I'm sure he already
created he also says this like kind of
shady thing that's like I mean I
understand State strange Supreme is
supposed to be kind of an but
like what is he up to either way that's
it for my breakdown of season 2 episode
6 of what if huge thanks to Noah Chen
for helping me write this video I've
been extremely sick this holiday season
and even now I'm like sweating I'm
having a hard time but Noah Chen came in
and helped me so much we've got a lot
more what if breakdowns coming your way
it truly takes a village for us to do
this follow me on Twitter at Lulu
Clemens follow new rockstars and be sure
to subscribe subbe for more breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching and I'll see you
[Music]
later